bitcoin's price has been crashing
aggressively and there's people freaking
out but one of the things that you can
do right now is simply to take a deep
breath and go look at the actual
on-chain data on-chain data is one of
the most important data sets in the
world because it cannot lie all it shows
you is exactly what is happening in the
Bitcoin Network ultimately if we were
talking about public stocks or
Commodities or real estate there's all
sorts of lack of transparency and you
don't get real-time information but
on-chain metrics can tell us a lot about
the current environment and so if we
take a look here we can see that plan B
had a great tweet where he actually
showed that bitcoin's price it dropped
all the way to twenty five thousand four
hundred dollars that almost touched the
realized price of about twenty four
thousand dollars now realize price is
one of these really interesting on-chain
metrics it basically takes all of the
Bitcoin in existence and it says what
was the price of that Bitcoin the last
time that it traded hands it adds up all
those prices and it reaches the Bitcoin
realized capitalization that metric
specifically is a way to think about
what the cost basis of all Bitcoin
holders on chain is and so with Bitcoin
at 24 25 000 it means that bitcoin's
current price is sitting about Break
Even to the cost basis of all Bitcoin
holders now obviously Bitcoin could go
lower than that cost basis but if
history serves as any sort of example
usually anywhere near that bottoming of
the realized capitalization meeting the
current price of Bitcoin that tends to
be a great sign that we are somewhere
near the Bottom now I wouldn't trade off
of this advice I actually no matter what
happens to bitcoin's price don't do much
things different I simply continue to
personally dollar cost average into the
asset and so I want to only use this
information just to be informed want to
understand what's happening in the
market and I want to constantly check my
thesis but some people will continue to
Simply look at Twitter sentiment or look
at non-factual information they'll go on
the internet they'll search around
they'll read headlines they'll get
scared they'll get nervous they'll have
all sorts of uncertainty and that'll
create mass chaos chaos but if you
continue to Simply look at the data and
understand what's happening you can see
that hash rate is still strong that
realized cap and the current market
price are meeting and there continues to
be an enormous amount of Interest both
in the number of users that are using
the Bitcoin Network every day and the
number of nodes in the lightning Network
and also in the transaction volume sure
there's some volatility in some of these
metrics but the underlying fundamentals
still look very strong and so as price
crashes you have two ways to look at it
one is through a fearful perspective
where you think the world is ending the
other is through a positive perspective
an optimistic one in which maybe there's
opportunity everywhere hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure to subscribe like the
video and see you next time